fifty years ago Berkeley California was
famous for its free speech activism
today it is a very different place this
week Berkeley City Council unanimously
unanimously declared to be the world in
quote a climate emergency to fix that
emergency Berkeley called for a push to
halt all carbon emissions worldwide and
said governments must make efforts to
quote humanely stabilize population a
phrase Rose Vieira would surely love and
a che Hussein is a writer and protocol
commentator and she joins us tonight
thanks all for coming on thanks so much
for having me so I I'm a pretty literal
person they say it's a climate emergency
sounds right to me so if it's an actual
emergency why does anyone in Berkeley
have an air-conditioner or maybe they
really believe it's sincere I mean I I
hate to sort of ask that people live out
their purported beliefs but if they're
telling the rest of us we need to have
fewer kids why are they still driving
and using AC honestly you know I totally
agree with you Tucker but I also don't
think they're just telling us to have
less babies I mean climate change and
the impact that human beings have on
environment is related to a lot of stuff
not just the amount of children that
we're having it's about carbon emissions
it's about eating less meat so I think
we can all agree that we care about our
planet but it's not just about having
less children oh no and I don't think it
is totally and no idea is insane and
grotesque and it's a it's a window into
what this really is which is social
Berkeley didn't mention how is that what
they're stationaries it's an emergency
it's a babies okay but hold on if they
are saying it's an emergency presumably
they believe it is so how can they
justify riding buses having cars
refrigerators any activity that adds to
the sum total of co2 emissions exact
emitting these activities no no I'm sure
why should I listen and take anyone
seriously who is driving a car and
simultaneously telling me not to have
more kids well I don't think they're
saying that it's a combination of
factors and the climate is really
complex tucker right it's not just one
thing you need to stop having babies I
need to stop writing my car I think in
general the younger generation the
Millennials are becoming more
environmentally cautious we have more
ride-sharing apps I mean I think the
technology is catching up to the fact
that people are becoming more conscious
people are much poorer because they are
deeply in student loan debt and they
have no money consciousness conscious
Millennials are okay that's also one
part of it there's more than one factor
but for when it comes to climate change
and what we can do to reduce our impact
right look I'm I actually am in favor of
a clean environment so I wonder why have
you noticed this that places that spend
the most energy telling the rest of us
that the world is ending because of
climate change
also tend to have the dirtiest streets
and the largest number of people were
leaving themselves on the sidewalk and
the most trash why not if you really
care about the environment maybe you
could clean up the sidewalk in front of
City Hall does that ever occur to
liberals I wonder you know what not just
liberals it's not liberals that are
responsible for climate change it's all
of us and I agree with you we can't just
talk the talk we have to you know also
follow up with actions and why no but
seriously
if you care about the environment and
making the world cleaner and by the way
we all agree that we agree with that we
all want to keep the environment cleaner
and yeah but yeah you've been to
Berkeley recently have you been to New
York City if you've been to San
Francisco there are people I think the
trousers down relieving themselves on
the sidewalk
you know I'm looking around for
environmentalists on the way to lectures
I have yeah you know what it's not
necessarily about where in the world is
more populated it's not who is using
more resources and I completely agree
with you we all have what you're talking
past each other can can you agree that
if we're going to make the world cleaner
we can start by cleaning up the
sidewalks and then maybe we can get to
the part about
fixing the hole in the ozone layer yes
maybe either or it's everyday what is it
why are the cities with the the most
open and aggressive commitment to the
environment the dirtiest why is Portland
Oregon a filthy place down with
everybody important environment I'm
talking specifically about Portland but
not all in cities that are saying that
we need to do better about our
environment are filthy where are you
getting that stat from okay but just
track with me really quick just for this
one question if you say you care about
the environment do you agree or disagree
that maybe you should start by cleaning
up the street in front of your house
it's not why can't you do both do both
I'm not saying you can't do both but why
is it like you're lecturing me about the
environment live not environments that
are about the planet we can all do more
right no we don't all care about the
planet we care about the planet that's
why my house has nobody sleeping on the
front step because I care about the
environment oh really
on a shake great to see you thanks for
having me